this is ambitious new gtx 750ti
a mid-range graphics card that's set to
retail for just a hundred and fifteen
pounds in the UK and 149 dollars in the
US and usually nvidia is using the gtx
750ti to launch its brand-new GM 107
Maxwell architecture the follow-up to
the Kepler architecture that's powered
the last two generations of the
company's GPU lineup Maxwell is still
based on the same 28 nanometer
fabrication process as Kepler yet
promises much greater power savings and
performance and video is claiming up to
twice the performance per watt and twice
the performance of the gtx 550 team i
what that means for you is a card that
is smaller quieter and uses just 60
watts of power without the need for a 6
pin power connector this makes it an
ideal fit for small form back two pcs
like steam machines or as an upgrade for
cheap off-the-shelf computers from the
likes of Dell and HP that features small
power supplies without extra power
connectors but does Maxwell's focus on
efficiency mean it hasn't got the chops
to run the latest games
amazingly no Nvidia claims the 750 Ti
matches or betters the performance of
this old flagship GPU the GTX 480 and in
our testing we found it to be a great
performer and of course it spanked the
hell out of Intel's integrated graphics
no you aren't going to be running Crysis
3 ultra settings with this thing but
I'll handle most games at 1080p on high
or very high settings at very good frame
rates on our Ivy Bridge I 5 powered test
rig we saw averages of 61 frames per
second in Tomb Raider 63 frames per
second in BioShock Infinite 52 frames
per second in battlefield 4 and 45
frames per second in Metro last light
and if you were thinking of plunking
down a hefty 429 pounds or $499 for an
xbox one just to play titanfall why not
just chuck 750ti
into an old PC at home it runs the beta
of the new
a shooter at a cool 58 frames per second
at 1080p with two times anti-aliasing on
not even the Xbox one can do that the
gtx 750ti runs cold runs incredibly
quiet than is fantastic value you can
chuck this thing into pretty much any
old PC with the spare PCI Express slot
and run the latest games without having
to worry about crazy cooling or if your
power supply can take the strain plus
you're getting all the great stuff that
comes with an nvidia card the brilliant
driver support shadowplay for recording
gameplay clips and chief force
experience for one-click setup of your
games if you're after a great performing
mid-range budget card without any of the
bus there's no better option than the
gtx 750ti right now high end users hold
tight hopefully this is a sign of great
things to come from nvidia x' brand new
maxwell chips too